we drank every day had sex multiple
times every day for four straight months
i started to wonder if this was a
competition
that's oprah winfrey reading a candid
confession from will smith about his sex
life with his wife jada pinkett smith in
his new memoir will it's a good time for
the smiths right now the actor sits down
with the media mogul for her series the
oprah conversation on apple tv plus and
opens up about the early days of his
relationship with jada whom he married
back in 1997. as far as i was concerned
there were only two possibilities i was
going to satisfy this woman sexually or
i was going to die try
and while the couple may have been hot
and heavy back then will said it was and
still is a lot deeper than that
me and jada to this day if we start
talking
it's four hours it's four hours if we
exchange a sentence really yeah and it's
like it's
uh it's the center of
why we've been able to sustain and
you know
why we're still
uh
together not
choking the life out of each other all
that echoes what will told et about how
they make it work back in 2007. it is
not your responsibility to make your
wife happy right
just like it's not my wife's
responsibility to make me happy
it's my responsibility to make me happy
and it's her responsibility to make her
happy and then we're going to come
together
and build on that happiness as for jada
will says she was never interested in a
traditional marriage in fact she didn't
even want a wedding their union it's all
about bettering themselves and coming
together stronger will and jada
are
on a spiritual journey to cleanse the
poisonous unloving parts of our hearts
wow
and
we're doing it together
in this lifetime
no matter what
right
but the goal
is
not a sexual goal
really at the end of the day
it's
just not quitting you know but it's not
the first time we've heard about how the
smiths keep things intimate last month
jada opened up about their sex life
after two decades of marriage on her
facebook watch series red table talk can
you expect your partner to know
especially when it comes to sex
it's like well if you love me you should
know right
you know what i mean if you love me you
should be able to you should read my
mind yeah you know that's a huge that's
a huge
and will shared a similar sentiment
during a chat with et back in 2007.
anything that i need to make myself
happy
i will present that to my wife that i
need that to be happy divorce is not an
option we going to be together so we
going to figure out how to be happy in
fact he doubled down on all that again
in 2015 telling e.t that when it comes
to their marriage they put in the work
you can't expect it to
be easy it's like
our marriage was the most difficult
grueling and excruciating thing that
we've ever
taken on in our lives and you know we're
just not quitters and by the same token
we're not apathetic we only ever worked
on ourselves individually and then
presented ourselves to one another
better than we were previously and
during his chat with oprah will also
talks about going to peru and doing
ayahuasca something he says was a
transformative experience for how he
views his relationship with his wife in
the experience i saw jada as soil and i
saw me as a seed
and
i saw what felt like the hand of god put
me as a seed into the soil of jada and
this big giant tree
grew with all of this fruit but i
started to think about
my relationship with jada
as being
a
fruitful
interaction
you